[Music]
and faith in humanity restored news
oye submitted my panda Linda I don't
know listen listen Olli Sabel icily no
no no honey honey listen Linda I wanted
to punch Nicky in the face customers buy
out their local donut shop early every
day so the owner can be with his sick
wife [ __ ] dope how can we make fun of
this still I blinked out on her with
sick wife what happened so did this guy
you own the donut shop all the customers
come in and go hey you know let's just
buy out all your inventories we could
shut down the store for a day and you
can go hang out your sick wife I'd start
making extra doughnuts
[Music]
every time they come she gets better and
I'm not even gonna tell anybody she got
better that's good he's like it today
it's 1,000 doughnuts guys I can't take
advantage of the situation there's a
Cambodian Placerville beach Oh see Beach
Cambodia Bodhi ins no so this couple
they are refugees from Cambodia they
came in 1979 you know they're donuts are
good yep yeah and so they've had their
shot there since then but recently John
Chan's wife Stella she got an aneurysm
of Rina you know and it's been very
debilitating to the point where now
she's like trying to learn how
heed and walk and everything but they
obviously still need to be running the
donut shop so then what what's been
happening is that people notice that
Stella wasn't at the donut shop anymore
they were asking John like what happened
to her and they he told them and so they
offered to set up a GoFundMe account for
him but he refused he was like no I just
want more time with my wife and so
instead customers started spreading I
don't blow my cover do I'm illegal I
don't have paperwork [ __ ] instead
that's when customers start spreading
the word like hey if you buy donuts here
like just buy a dozen at a time so you
can fill out or Oh [ __ ] don't ya
that's beautiful if you're a business
owner it's so hard to take charity yeah
cuz it's like I already I want to earn
my living you know I don't know I can
kind of feel what this guy's feeling
like a pencil smudge it's just like
let's just die so you start drawing
that's crazy what kind of shape is that
you know what it reminds me of they're
still it's like back in a day like like
villains from like that I will kill you
Michael oh yeah it looks like a painted
cloud almost you know I always start
making a pause is full since people are
gonna buy a dozen at a time I'm only
gonna make Siamese Donuts so I'll take
two Donuts I'll fuse them in the middle
now those two Donuts are one so when
people buy 12 they're technically buying
24 everything bear claws [ __ ] sign
these bear claws oh yeah even the donut
holes and the holes now puts you like
this I think he's worried about his wife
dude boss Ivy's Donuts bad he's not
thinking of ways to reinvent his donut
business yeah shows you what kind of
people we are black people also like
damn if Bart had a donut shop it'd be
bomb as [ __ ] but he only makes enemies
donut that's true cuz a donut will be
eight and Rouge binocular Donuts crazy
one of my friends in high school
had one and I guess it's like a blood
clot in the brain right or something
like that it's a part it's a first to
type off s and it could be like fatal
too so like this dude
I guess they he got the operation before
anything got too serious and this guy
he's such a [ __ ] clown like he was in
the hospital and this fool was like
laying in bed and he was like can you
feed that to me I can't get I found the
applesauce is for listening in we're all
worried about it was he could've died he
go see drugs after surgery he had a
bigger joke hell yeah and doughnut shops
are he's finding donut shops are hard as
[ __ ] to run dude dude I swear half the
donut shops in LA are front for jobs I'm
like there's like a donut shop at every
corner basically like where I live they
make a lot of money on coffee so like
people could be buying Donuts all day
but most of the money comes from coffee
yeah but then the Starbucks is slam to
I'm like I only see the Starbucks slam I
never see anybody in there but in your
area everyone's living on top of
everyone that's how there's no street
parking that's true that's true
I mean I would love to have a donut shop
I would do you gotta wake up at like
3:00 a.m. to bake the donuts to start or
whatever I'm wakin up it's crazy yeah
it'sit's really hard
I wonder who taught like Cambodia people
how to make donuts like how do you know
who it's my you know Joey or friend yeah
his uncle is the donut King they made a
documentary about him he's one of the
first few Cambodians that started they
learned off of some guy that had like a
franchise like Winchell's or whatever Oh
Duncan it was like a dude that he he
employed some Cambodian refugees any
taught him the trade and he's held up
all the nut on well he helped them open
up some shops and stuff like that but
the guys you have no faith before your
asian guy he died so what we do is you
people were gonna steal you should have
making it better that's like our thing
like every like Korean people are the
best at that [ __ ] you can tell
everybody show ideas music and then we
just bring it to Korea and then we see
it's kpop no they did they didn't steal
it but they were yeah they were taught
the trade and then they were they gave
them an opportunity to kind of open up
shop and do all that stuff so what
they'll do is they'll open up a doughnut
shop and indels once they get
citizenship
they'll sponsor other family members
from Cambodia to come and Indo working
up they're gonna show their work that
yeah donut shop like an indentured
servant though so like the the family
will front the the whole process like in
pay right yeah and then the people will
work it off and that's how they make
profit because like they technically
have free labor oh wow so yeah and then
so once their family members paid off
the debt then they can save up money and
then they'll franchise or build another
donut shop and that's how the Cambodian
things spread dude some of the best
sandwiches that you can get are to the
donut shop sandwiches oh yeah favorite
[ __ ] is the ham and egg and cheese
Cambodian croissant sandwich oh yeah
that [ __ ] is good
[ __ ] it all the good dude and I got a
place next to me too that's its Mexican
food and sushi there's a lot of spots
like that dude there's one in [ __ ]
Boyle Heights this what's it called
what you mean it's donuts Mexican food
and sushi no it's just you see it
throughout the restaurant and I'm like
how does this work I want to go in and
check it out just we got a donut shop
right here that sells water cigarettes
and Donuts and it's a bus stop for
Chinese tourism whole thing is like
donuts the sandwiches or dorrance people
want to travel I'm thirsty and I have a
nicotine addiction what can I go you
know yeah cuz people are smoking
cigarettes for scratching lotto tickets
they're bringing in [ __ ] 5-gallon
those water jugs you're getting that
filled up and they're selling the one
dollar Arizona iced teas for a dollar
fifty cents even though it's printed on
their agent myself or dog [ __ ] always
happens always
I wanted to own a donut shop one day
though like because I had friends that
did it but do they I saw the whole
process go down then it is back-breaking
deve it's so romantic though right like
yeah I wake up in the morning I make
donuts like you know I have customers on
[ __ ] but in LA it changes everything I
want to be the regular that goes there
the like regular that goes are by my
newspaper gets coffee gets my donut sit
down relax eat some donuts
retry [ __ ] wait wait for your kids to
call
alright recent newspaper scratch a lotto
ticket yeah that's fun don't know is
he's like stare at your phone wait for
your kids to call yeah I'm hoping they
don't call I'm like don't you [ __ ]
dare bother scratch a lot of ticket and
oh and then you won two bucks and then
you walk up the register and you cash it
yeah how fun so fun that sounds like the
worst life ever dude shoot myself in the
face dude
what do you want to do then I would go
to Hawaii lay on a beach eat some food
chill out I'll go to Hawaii but I'm
gonna find a donor shop to hang out at
yeah do that after you wake up in the
morning and eat a donut and smoke two
packs of cigarettes paper and then
scratch a lotto ticket
then you go fishing at the baby
newspapers now I don't really think that
you know somebody into another routine I
don't even know of my own I'm my own
dad's routine this like I don't think I
really know is your is your dad or mom a
routine person they are yeah but I don't
know the routine
so how well do I know them that's what I
wonder I know my dad's routine he wakes
up in the morning pisses my mom off my
mom yells oh hey hey wonder why I go
take the dogs out play with the dogs
feed them whatever go to work comes back
home he go hops on the internet sees
what I'm doing calls me up says hey
you'll be really great for your YouTube
and I hang up on him and he goes to
sleep next day we started all over
very good there it is Bart's dad's
really routine like because I lived at
the house before person yeah
he I've never met anyone that was so
clockwork like you know basically I kind
of knew his schedule like what days he
would go to work what and then he would
be doing the same thing like after work
he would watch this Chinese parade and
he would watch the same Chinese parade
like for months straight yeah it's like
a routine like he would watch that while
he make while he eats his soup and then
after that he would eat a Hershey's bar
or something once in a while his
girlfriend would come over and it would
be the same kind of like thing over and
over every Tuesday at 5:00 is his
cleaning time so if you show up at his
house at 5 o'clock on the dot on a
Tuesday you could guarantee he's
cleaning something that's his like house
cleaning day he's like [ __ ] o'clock
there's a Mexican guy who lives by us
and he always cleans his Mini Cooper but
he has to blast Mexican music while he's
cleaning his Mini Coopers all of them
and it's it's every Monday night every
no matter what
so it's last night me and if you're
trying to watch making a murder - and
this cat's out there like you know
fluffing out his car mats and [ __ ] like
to the loudest music it's just the
typical Mexican polka music it came from
actual Germans that moved to Texas and
then they influenced that Mexican sound
with their polka I was like mind blown
like whoa it's like it's that IIIi stuff
with all the different you think he was
listening to that exact song like it's
hilarious the kinds of gray he less is
the same one every week it's his
favorite jam you know what it's like to
be structured like that I wish I had
that thing like I could wake up and just
do the same thing every day be myself I
get so happy I'm saying like I would
like to be that person that enjoys
enjoys it that makes them happy because
they don't have to think and I'm not
like that but they don't have to like
always wonder like okay what is this
gonna make me happy is this they just do
the same routine and they live happy in
they die I would love that [ __ ] I like I
like that I like oh I don't like a full
like I don't want to be like an animal I
just stuck in a zoo or something but I
like knowing when my routine times on
than when my exploration times are we
know my max is two weeks I figured out
my max of doing routinely scheduled
things is two weeks at two weeks I need
to do something just kind of like on the
fly for one day I got two days of
structure and then I'm gonna explode
that's what it is yeah like literally
it's like two days I'm like David this
is what you knew you schedule it out and
after on day three I'm like I'm gonna
[ __ ] kill myself I'm just I don't
think that that exists in my father were
like he wakes up in the morning and he's
gonna fix computers all day that's like
what he does and he he puts on black a
black shirt black slacks and Fela shoes
every
he goes and gets his newspaper and then
that's where his routine starts to fade
away to me because I don't I'm not sure
you should call him up and say what do
you do yeah well how do you do that
without sounding like offensive like
what do you do all day
oh ok with you but I don't want to
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you